Lee starts off this hour in Rhode Island
at least how are you hey I'm having
trouble hearing you can you speak
directly into your phone please hello
yes ma'am
okay try again okay fangirl but I'm
fangirling right now ah
we're honored thank you how can we help
okay so I saw that very unique situation
last year I actually got divorced but I
recently moved back in with my
ex-husband and we're doing really well
pretty much he's treating everything
like nothing ever happened
we got married under God so we're still
married and I'm like well maybe we
should like get married again so that
way we can put like finances together
but he's like no I like it the way it is
because you know we put the finances and
everything and the only marry me if I
buy in the $50,000 car are you kidding
yeah so you you are attracted to someone
that would not marry you unless you
bought them a $50,000 car okay she says
that if I really want in because after
the whole divorce thing that this would
like prove and I'm like submitted or
whatever I'm not sure how how old are
you
wait 28 okay Lee this this guy's
terrible there why did you get why did
you get a divorce
Wow two years ago when you guys got
divorced what was the reason for that
was a year had me why infidelity yeah
and the reason he doesn't want to get
legally married to you again he's saying
is because of the money and I'm gonna
bet probably something else so Lee I
think that your instincts first off were
rights I'm telling you if my husband if
we are ever
we were in our serious relationship
about to be married and he said in order
to marry me you're gonna have to buy me
a $50,000 car I would say well enjoy the
$50,000 car because I'm leaving and
you're not gonna be getting that like
like that's Slee like that's that's
there's there's a lot of dysfunction
there do you know that do you understand
that cars for you to marry house like
that like the 50,000 isn't the point
though it's like there's an asset there
that he's asking for like do you get
that part and I put a lot of stress and
everything so I don't have that money so
okay you let me let me let me let me
stop you okay kiddo here's the thing you
need to go see a good pastor and a good
marriage counselor and start to get some
help okay
due to the infidelity you running around
on him you got divorced and you feel
really guilty for that and now he's
using that to manipulate you and so you
guys are a serious pair mess here
there's no way that this is going to end
in a positive situation without a lot of
help
and you've got it he's got to understand
what forgiveness is you have to
understand how to accept that
forgiveness if he were to give it and
forgive yourself for the mistakes you
made in the past and start with a clean
slate and on equal footing and move
forward but there's no possible way you
put up a dowry to marry this guy that
says that's just asinine that's just
ridiculous
and if you were my daughter this is what
I would tell you okay I would say honey
pick up your stuff and go get you an
apartment today go see a marriage
counselor and if you guys go through
some in-depth marriage counseling
together and can work through a healing
of your relationship maybe you talked
about getting remarried after that but
it certainly won't involve you giving
him anything of value in return for your
guilt or your regret or to prove your
love
or any other BS now let me tell you what
I think I think you're not going to do
any of that because your mass girl and
so I wish you would I love you and I
want you to have good things in your
life and I you know very few people in
your life are telling you the truth
they don't care enough about you to tell
you the truth and I'm telling you the
truth you need to get out of there today
this is a Twisted Sister mess and it's
not going to end in a 50-year marriage
with you two sitting on the front porch
with grandkids around your feet it's not
going to end that way you don't have a
basis for that you don't have a
foundation for that now could it end up
there if you go through the steps I'm
telling you to go through it's possible
but it's not likely because I think he's
lacking in character and like Rachel
said this is a guy you need to run from
but if you don't run from him and you
want to move out and seek some
counseling and try to rebuild a
relationship on a solid emotional
foundation then you can do that now you
can do whatever you want to I'm not a
family counselor I'm just an old guy
who's seen a lot of crap and a lot of
crappy people to crappy stuff to each
other and hurt each other in the process
so and in that like you're saying that
there's a lot of shame a lot of guilt
you know a lot of lack of forgiveness
there's a lot of human qualities there
that are very very evident and in order
to make the relationship right take the
money stuff out of it completely but
focusing there just on that relationship
as you two as individuals the healthier
you both can become and then coming
together yes we'll be you know we'll
create the formula for the marriage to
be possibly withstanding other things
but but oh there there's a lot of
dysfunction there and just that and just
that question I'm sorry sorry you know I
wish you had a better situation but let
me tell you what you allow in your life
is what's going to take place and you're
allowing a shame-based booty call as all
you're doing here that's all that's
going down and you know you're gonna
have to decide are you worth it or not
to stand up and walk out of there and
say I'm gonna have a different situation
and I'm going
I'm gonna rebuild my life and I'm gonna
have a solid foundation that I go to but
that's all this is it's just back to the
original thing that drew you guys
together which was a physical connection
and that's drawing you back together and
he wants to act like nothing's going on
except that he wants a 50,000 hour car
of course there's something going on his
heart still screwed up he's still mad
he's still angry but you know but we can
live together
you know it's um I'm sorry honey I wish
you had a different situation my heart
breaks for you
it really does that's what I would tell
my daughter and I don't I don't know if
you'll do it or not I hope you do it but
I hope you get some good solid men and
women in your life that can guide you
and love you well through this and help
you up and keep your mind focused on
things that'll work